[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
for me everyone should be able to see me
as well i'm here with my right hand man
or am i your right hand man i'm i'm
unsure these days man we
we we
that's what's up so you know we're here
again you know we're at the attic show
where we talk about all about gaming
got king in here because i know you guys
like to hear him him rant
and uh you know a shout out to king so
first off king
what are you playing man like i know
you'd be over there i saw the mlb
it will we'll definitely talk about that
but what have you been playing
i've been playing mlb the show
oh my god i'm playing that and out right
i'm really grinding my gear now right is
uh there's a little nuances a lot of
people
play the surface of games and they don't
get into the nuances of the game
and there are a ton of nuances to the
game a lot of you guys don't know what
your attributes are
and and what are you breaking down stuff
for and stuff like that so
right now i'm exploring my build uh i
can do
up to 160 million damage
so far that's where i'm at so i'm right
now soloing uh
tier 12 expeditions um
it's a really cool thing i'm trying to
get up to
you know tier 15 expeditions but emil
beat the show
uh i started off as the yankees yankees
is my team
and uh i'm i'm really going to play a
season this time
this time i'm going to commit myself to
playing the season the whole 162 games
and hopefully i can get to the playoffs
this seems like a lot man like
i've always liked the concept behind
sports games where you know you trade
people off you
you fight your way up the the league but
i've never got into them because i just
don't watch sports so i can't really
it's like an rpg though it is but
it's it's not it's it's not the same
this like i'm not i'm not hitting
people's swords i'm hitting
i'm hitting a ball baseball back or you
or you are you dribbling and shooting
balls in the hoop
it's the same premise of an rpg
in the fact that you're managing the
team um
you know it's it's really deep a lot of
these basketball games
it's not like double dribble back in the
days or uh nba jam
you know it's it's really deep you know
you have to you know work with
personalities and stuff like that some
dudes are disgruntled on teams and want
to be traded
yeah i've always noticed how cool it is
that kind of concept uh you know
i'm not really i don't really know a
whole lot about sports but i do
you know i know like the key players
that people complain about every year
like lebron tom brady
so like i see those but as far as like
the game
like logistically i know zero about but
you
you know what i've been playing king
i've been playing that octopath traveler
what is that in king what is that it
listen game pass
you know um i purchased that that that
game on our switch
um never thought it would come the game
pass and you know phil dominus max mr
really expensive
surprises us every day and put that game
in game pass
and i could have saved myself my 60
bucks or whatever i paid for the game
to you know play it in game pass so yeah
it's it's a really good game though i'm
not gonna yeah i think i think i'm like
15
20 hours into it and like see i get i
get obsessed when it comes to being op
i want the best gear i want the best
armor and i love the mechanics in this
game because you could just pop up to
anyone
popped up to the the chick buying some
some groceries
for dinner that night be like yo what
you got for sale and then you look at it
i was like oh you
you got this knife i seen this knife i
want this knife
it's 34 grand like
[Laughter]
yeah yo so in that game
is what is it five to six characters
that you're picking that you can pick
from in the beginning they're like
i i got okay i had six characters and
there's still two left i haven't
unlocked so there's eight right
yeah so this is but there's potentially
uh
a ton of different endings right with
attendance i don't
i don't know i just finally started
doing the second mission because
i look king i got so obsessed i'm level
like 35.
in chapter one
because it's so open you can go really
anywhere you want to for the most part
like
there are certain areas that i think
that unlock the longer the game goes
right but like i'm just sitting here
grinding it and i was i was in a party
with
cognito on them last night and i'm just
sitting here like blind grinding
and like because i got tired of getting
killed because um
the the experience is kind of weird so
i'm just sitting like all right so
then i look and i'm like i need to i
need a level up so you know i had to do
that google
did that google i was like where's the
best place to level up the level i'm at
and they tell me this uh this place so
i'll go there
and there uh i didn't read all of it
read everything when you read guides but
so i'm sitting there looking at it
so they're like well these people hit a
little hard so i'm like they hit a
little hard they ain't gonna kill me
do one shot at me word so so i'm like
man
i'm sitting there and i look and i'm
like oh
they want me to be level 28 and i'm 21.
so i so like and then the like the the
the
the i can't i can't quit person m he was
like no i could take these people
like nah nah that that eight level gap
is nothing
and i sat there and i grinded
differently for like an hour and i
finally started beating them and i
started like grinding
i started going up like a level or two
every time i uh won a battle but
i think it's unique i think there's a
lot of concepts in that game that could
have been really evolved mm-hmm
sixty dollars definitely wasn't worth it
though like i can already
it's free now so
you didn't pay anything you know uh so
it's definitely worth the price of
exhibition
and and to be honest with you for it to
have uh consumed you in this manner i
don't know
i don't know i'm just like it's just
little things like i i
i don't like the fact that there's
multiple characters because like it
sounded cool at first but when you go to
like these other
levels and you do them they don't even
acknowledge the other people with you
it's like they're not there and i'm just
like you might as well just had one
character
and then they go through the rest of the
game like people
it's not like uh what we was playing on
out of worlds
and the characters get a chance to
interact and talk the only people
not i don't know maybe after you do all
their missions then maybe there's like a
a mains mission that yeah that
incorporates them all because
these are their origin stories i
obviously i don't expect their origin
stories to be there
but literally i remember this park king
i was doing this
i was fighting this this this this
juggalo do pretty much and he's sitting
on top of his
it's the dancers main uh villain for her
origin
he's like you're all alone and i'm like
no i got two people with me
i'm not all those so like stuff like
that took me out of the experience a
little bit okay
so yeah they didn't acknowledge the fact
that you have people
all right so let's let's let's move on
to
mlb the show clearly there's been a lot
of stuff going on with mlb
mlb is finally in people's hands uh lord
king i
how long have you played mlb okay so i
didn't really play too long
um i was playing the yankees versus the
dodgers and i got a game in
and um well i didn't start my season yet
because i want to start my season fresh
i just played the x-music
exhibition game and i feel that
you know to get the best out of these
games you start a fresh season you start
off from the beginning
and they have a lot of little cut scenes
and stuff you get a chance to have
either a broadcast uh view or the show
view or hybrid of the two
and it's it's graphically
i already told people it's it's the the
best baseball game that you're ever
going to see
it does i i was seeing uh cognito you
kept posting uh
because i went i i i went to bed but all
since i went in there and started
watching some show called snowfall that
people won't shut up about on twitter
yeah i like it i like it uh so i'm
watching this and then every time
because i have you and cog belled so
every time you post something that pops
up
i see it called post i already know this
is mlb i don't even need to click this
and now but obviously i clicked it it
was
it was clips from mmob and i think that
the reason this is so big
people like myself i don't care i
probably will play a couple games
because i like
i used to play baseball when i was a kid
i was like in the little minor league
things
up until i was like 13 or 14 but then i
shattered my ankle
and it's just never been the right sense
it's so i'm sitting here and um
i i know and i have to hand my hat off
to wha what's his name phil what
maximus aurelius spencer went over there
to sony not only did he say
yo we need that baseball game we need
that baseball game better than what you
are getting that baseball game
and you know i got that is literally
walking into someone's
house to be like i want this house like
you can't have this house
he comes back six months later this is
my house
it's absolutely wild like when i booted
it up
and the sony logo comes up
i have my xbox controller and i know
it's like
i can't wait for digital foundry to come
out with their with their if it's in 4k
or whatever if it's native 4k or
whatever i just want to see the
side-by-side comparisons
um but it's
he did it man he got
their first party studio game day and
date
on his platform and not in their
platform that's monumentous
that's that's that's something totally
otherworldly i don't think you can do
anything more gangster than that
like i told you he's he's a bond villain
now i don't care what no one says
everybody can say whatever anybody that
sat there said he's the nicest guy in
the world and he likes to kiss babies
and shake hands and all this other crap
i don't care what you say for him
to have yo flagship sports title
that has only been on your console for
its entire inception to
now his conception to inception to here
and
for it to only be there and for to make
its debut
on your service for whoever is in your
service
for free because
game pass paid for itself already so far
for me this year
so for free every baseball fan should
jump up and down
and if you love baseball and baseball
season is right now and it's going
you don't get a chance to go out to the
games i'm telling you
this game looks second to none and no
more
he took he get he literally took the
reason and if he was a baseball fan
that you was waiting to get a
playstation 5 or you're trying to get a
playstation
out of it took he took it out of your
hands you don't have to worry anymore
you don't have to spend
that five six hundred dollars plus the
game to play baseball and that was what
uh
uh sovereign was doing for years he
would get a playstation
just to get him to be the show yeah and
you know
i it's like i said i'm not i'm not a
sports person i have nothing in the
sports
race but it's just like why is a
baseball game exclusive in the first
place like
like and i feel i feel like mlb realized
that in the end they're like look
we got to make money he's he's like
let's put this everywhere we can
if sony got an issue with we'll just get
the license to ea
like yeah so i think sony was in a in a
predicament now i think sony
eventually accepted the fact that this
game was coming everywhere
but i think microsoft came in there in
the back end it was like
not only do we want it on xbox and they
they handed the bags like we wanted on
game
since it's dropped into them of these
heads
because i i'm pretty sure sony's a
little salty over there just a little
bit like that not a little bit
that's terrible that's that's the worst
look that you can ever have that's could
you imagine
if gears dropped
in this playstation now and not aside
game pass gears
because this is the equivalent of gears
i don't think
i don't think it's exactly the
equivalent of gears but i do for
sports dude this is gears yeah it is it
is
but i i don't think like in the realm uh
it's okay what is it i think forza would
be a better
uh i don't always think forza is a good
analogy because like it's a sports game
that is loved by a lot of people yeah it
was a sports game
and so i could understand i think that
would be a better analogy than gears
but you know it for's it's horizon
to four or five see but you undo it
hold up hold up let me finish let me
finish this
let me finish let me finish let me
finish forza horizon 5 comes out
and there's a scenario where it was on
playstation plus but not
xbox not game pass it wouldn't even be
around because
xbox would never allow that to happen if
something happened where they lost the
franchise it was on everything
and they heard sony was putting it on
get playstation now
or playstation plus i'm confident that
phil will be
phil would be on that phone he'd be like
put that in game pass right now
not yesterday right now like i don't
know why
jim dance moves ryan didn't do it i
don't know
they wanted that money man but they're
gonna get the money anyway see this this
is the problem this is the
in their philosophy this is where the
problem is then
you don't believe in your product that's
all you don't believe in your product
because once somebody get a taste of
your product for free they're going to
want to pay for it
regardless to what you know just very
simple if it's a good product you
believe in your product you put your
product out there
let the people sample your product and
they love it they will
come back for more i think what it is is
sony
they're making money off of that so they
don't want to just like they don't want
to exchange the money they're going to
make it a good portion because it
wouldn't be cheap
you know they have access to that but
they're kissing some of the profits that
they're going to be making for they're
not going to kiss anything
and i think that's the reason they
didn't put that on playstation if they
want all that money playstation now
and residuals for people that are
constantly coming back and forth
this that's the problem with their
business model their business model is
too archaic
it is too old it's two last gen it is
two it's two
stone ages i'll agree with you there
it definitely is i i felt you know we
see it now we see
uh you know services like game pass
that's making sony look bad
and it's it's not even directly it's
indirectly like yeah
you're snatching gay you're snatching
game uh you're snatching mlb
it's making sony look like their own
stuff's going on game pass
and then you know obviously a lot of
people aren't gonna you know
they're gonna just have the assumption
like if they're willing to let mlb
jump in game pass what's next like what
else are they not gonna stop from coming
to game pass
like right now they they don't oh it's
it's a misconstruction
uh misconstruction it is a very
bad thing that people feel you know
people feel like sony owns the
spider-man
uh license for the game they don't they
own the movie license and they
lease the spider-man license how do we
know
in the next game whatever their title is
their contract
marvel hits them up with i want it
everywhere like it's so is so is sony
just going to let it go like that
because they don't technically own it
that's what that's what i mean like
my thing is this is how i see it why
don't they make insomniac
[Music]
what if what if what if disney
does the same exact thing that
mlb did and does the same
exact thing and now you have to have
that spiderman and then you know it's
coming date and date
do you think that's something that's
possible though yes and is it is it
totally in the realm of power we never
thought this baseball thing is in the
realm of the possibility
we know now that anything's possible
and anything's possible when you don't
own something outright
now a lot of people are saying that oh
god war never come
this is a scenario i can give you right
god of war is not making any more money
now or the old ip let's say it's the old
the first one i'm well this the last one
five or whatever the hell it is
right and it comes out on pc it sells
whatever it sells on pc
they're up to god of war three
why not put it on the xbox so why not
get that xbox money
so you're saying that sony will see the
money they're making off game pass and
they'll say you know what we made this
money off
mlb why not god award is that what
you're saying
i'm i'm i'm i'm a star
storm starch believer in that whole
philosophy
in jim dance moves uh philosophy he's
complicit island told you he's complicit
in this whole thing
right but i honestly believe him being a
numbers guy
would say there's nothing wrong with old
ips making
money new money in other areas so
it would be like the same concept they
have with the the pc market
let's put it on there because it doesn't
directly affect us because
it's already ran its course but they can
get money off of it
in the long run due to it being in game
pass
yes and i mean i just don't see
a ton of money i'll be real with you
like what are you holding on to
you're not using it anyway i guess
that's somebody
but putting it on pc and putting on on
on xbox game pass is a different variety
because if you put it on gamepad you
have to put it on xbox so you think that
they will put god of war on xbox
just to make a little money off gameplay
give you a scenario
let's say you and this better rival of
yours lives across the street right and
you have a turbo graphics in your house
you don't use it you don't play it you
don't use it
it's ran its courses did whatever it's
gonna do
somebody has his attention
yeah um sorry my brother he knows i'll
be in here doing this and he comes in
here the
exact time it runs its course right you
you already played the turbo graphic as
much as you plan and your bitter rival
across the street comes over and say hey
yeah i know that's what i'm telling him
i'm literally
waving him away and he's still right
there
i'm gonna start locking my door but uh
so all right your middle rival comes
over and says
yo let me borrow your turbo graphics and
i give you 500 dollars just to hold it
for a week
okay bar and
but that's that's a hardware thing like
i just don't see them like
when it comes to the exclusivity stuff
like they might hold strong with that
but i don't see them publishing he's
saying
you're saying he's complicit so he's
going to do it listen like yo
why make a why make your studios why i
make a sony studios
why become a a third-party publisher
why why are you saying why not or you
guys
know why they did already they are
so why well i don't know i don't
i don't have the answers king i'm giving
you the answer
i'm telling you you're prepping the yo
you're prepping the the
the the what is it the landing field you
you know how they they clean though
so there's no rubble on the floor if you
feel like this were to happen what kind
of time frame would you put it on as
soon as they see the residuals from this
yo i'm gonna tell you right now let's
okay here's a scenario
let's say mlb the show sells one million
copies on the playstation platform
one million right now and let's say it
sells
four or five million on the xbox
platform
what are you gonna tell your board that
that's a more viable
uh a place to sell stuff right so
they're gonna say why aren't we over
there now why don't why are we not
getting money from them
what is this imaginary boundaries that
we're holding ourselves captive to
but it wouldn't it be safe to assume
because they have this
stance on they're trying to be a little
bit more old-fashioned than microsoft
that it would be microsoft to do that
before zone
no listen microsoft is already doing it
like if you got doom
on on your playstation and it's in the
playstation store right now
if you got doom you got wolfenstein
that's inside the playstation store
right now
and you went and you purchased it right
now that's a microsoft product
okay you you you play minecraft right
now
on your playstation that's a microsoft
product okay i don't care how you want
to slice it
how you want to look at it you're
putting money in microsoft's pocket
regardless to what it's already being
done
so these imaginary barriers that people
are putting up
yeah you can't play halo over there
but it it's not a viable area
if it was a viable area for them to make
money
because sony's not making money so if
they're making money listen
they're not making money how you think
if every time you're looking at
bankruptcy i don't care what anybody
said oh so you're saying that they're
making money in the gaming industry it's
just not enough to keep the entire
company
right and there's ways for them to make
money hand over fist
i agree with you on that but microsoft
they there are more things but the
difference is they're profitable in
other things so
listen let me tell you this right you
know why i think the fear of them
allowing their game on another console
they will never do that like this is
that fair
they have an inferior product towards
the competitors product
and if you was to put that game because
mlb the show is going to show you right
now when digital foundry comes out and
then be like oh it's running the 4k
native 60 frames per second on xbox but
on the playstation
it's running in checkerboard 1880p right
you have a superior product that's over
here
that's the only thing that i can see
because then you can directly compare
what it is and then somebody will say
well i don't need to have a playstation
let me just buy an xbox and i could play
my playstation games over here
so it's better so uh let's get these
super chats because one of these super
chats is good and i think you'll
enjoy what he's saying and i can kind of
agree with this to a point
uh solutious octavius i definitely
butchered your name
we're going to move right past on to
that shout out to the two dollar
students hit that like button people
then uh keo walker said eve uh for the
five dollar super chat even if jim says
no to xbox console he might
he may say yes to game pass for pc and
xbox
cloud gaming i could actually see a
scenario where that could actually work
out for sony
because that's not directly on their
platform so i i
you know i don't think that would still
happen but that is the one i could see
happening the most
because this way every you don't notice
how everybody's always pissed off how
uh the pc and xbox game pass is like
really different like some of the games
aren't there and some of the games are
and it's like why that's not there why
they not you know the same thing
and i can see that scenario being true
well i will allow it on the pc game pass
and you can do it on cloud gaming but i
won't allow it on the console game pass
okay we'll take that yeah and i could
see microsoft
like what we're here sign here here here
here
click sign this one here that you won't
you won't take this back
sign this one here that you're sober
[Laughter]
somebody give him a breathalyzer we're
not giving them any room
to to get out of this in the long run
all right so uh we gotta find all the
stupid stuff from
k as to nada i definitely butchered your
name too you guys know this we're going
to move on
salute jets mlb plays great even on the
ios game pass on browser by the way i
watched
xbox game stack and suspiciously
suspiciously switch was
in multiple sessions something's up that
is a good point we can talk about that
briefly
look and you're educated king guest
we're gonna call it the educated king
guests
what is microsoft and switch doing i
would have said that they were going to
do
their servers right and um
i really honestly believe that they're
uh
working with them for the cloud gaming
infrastructure i i felt that nintendo
would have worked with nvidia because
the nvidia shield is so close to the
switch that it kind of mirrors it in a
way
and they already have that nvidia goal
and that situation
going on there but i think the fact that
uh microsoft
is uh the azure cloud
uh system is all over the world
allows them a little bit more
flexibility so
it's a difference between them going
with amazon
and going with microsoft i and phil said
this
before that he would you know uh help
uh playstation and help nintendo
and when you ask like how would he help
them
he would be helping them with the cloud
infrastructure like he did with sony so
i believe it is something in the kin
with uh
sony the same thing with nintendo i
don't think is as
much to do as everyone thinks it is
everyone wants it to be you know mario
we run
around on xbox now if something like
that happens
i don't know um i think that would rock
the industry to be honest with you
what happens if it's not a game pass
scenario but it's like
we're gonna bring the same like the same
game chat and stuff that's on
xbox to switch because clearly they're
lacking there but what is what would a
microsoft getting
because i'm sure there's some kind of
form of currency being switched between
them for them money is not money is
not going to that's not the smell test
you know um if it's a big deal then we
got to get something out of this deal
that is
uh how how can i say um
it's not visually pleasing it has to
it has to pass the smell test it has to
it has to show
so if if it looks right then fine
if it looks like we're both equally
winning here then we can do the deal but
if it looks like
only you're benefiting from this deal
because trust me
if microsoft was to help them with their
uh chat and all that other stuff
nintendo's actually getting a leg up and
if nintendo's the market leader why i'm
going to help you
more you know so i got to get something
out of this deal
something has to happen yeah so some
type of
so some kind of benefit on microsoft
that's not currency because they got the
currency like yeah
obviously they'll probably get some form
of cash payment but the biggest thing
that they're going to want
is some form of industry hold that they
can
leverage in the industry that only
nintendo can give them yeah because like
if it's a partnership
then it has to look good
like when when you when you show like
like bethesda
when they brought zenimax you see all
the commercials now
we're family we're team we we're doing
this together
we're brothers so
it's it's different you know so and we
all know microsoft owns them entirely
so technically it's not like that and i
think that'll go away
after at least five or six years that
whole we're brothers and
no no no it's actually microsoft you can
just make making xbox games
so honestly it's in the beginning
it just has to look different it has to
look it has to pass that test
so all right so you know we're going to
rail back a little bit i appreciate the
uh
the the the nice because i was i do
curious on what the switch is doing i
think we'll find that out a little bit
quicker later on this year uh but let's
let's let's talk about it okay uh
finally sony's came out and they said
we bend the knee to microsoft we know
that they backwards compatibility is
making everything lit
and we can't shut down the ps3 and the
ps vita
stores did you see this coming
no you thought they were just going to
keep it
no i thought um well i thought jim dance
was ryan is tone deaf
and i think this is above his pay grade
to make this call
i think they didn't like all the
negative press that's going around
because sony is used to being the
darling
sony is used to doing whatever and
everyone's still
looking and turning the other cheek
actually right now people are
questioning
every and anything that they're doing
and they're pointing out
all the little blemishes and flaws and
all the stuff that's going wrong with
sony
and they're actually questioning what
the hell is going on with sony
so this is for the for the first time in
sony's history they're being questioned
and they're being scrutinized and
they're being poked at and punched at
and i don't really think they like it i
really don't think
they like being the ugly little
stepchild
and something's wrong with them so at
this point i think
that they had a plan i thought the plan
was going to be to roll out something in
a package
that would have made playstation now a
little bit more pleasing and it would
turn it into a game pass type scenario
where they can have like 300 of their
ips available for
download and play inside the of the
service
and they can restructure it i think
i don't think that and let me explain to
you why i don't think that i feel like
if there was a scenario like that
where they were going to bring these
back in some kind of form i feel like
they would have told you
it just just to stop the bleeding like
look we know that we're getting rid of
the ps3 and ps vita but we have a
solution coming down the road
just bear with us maybe they give some
kind of generic
uh generic video on youtube
and then just keep it going like i feel
like them pushing back
and rotating it kind of like what
microsoft did earlier this year at the
xbox uh
gold i feel like that was stating we
were literally going to shut these down
off you because they cost us money we
ain't making money off them
but you guys attacked us too much on
twitter so we're going we're going to
turn that right back around that never
happened
that's just my opinion okay i can tell
you this
let's say this right let's say the
playstations was in plenty of supply
let's say that uh mlb the show was never
on game pass let's say
the ssd um solution their memory
solution was actually working
and they actually had games in a while
this little thing they would have been
closing down in those stores they would
kept going because there wouldn't have
been anything for anybody to say but the
fact that everybody's pointing a finger
at sony
we just don't need any more bad press so
this is one of the things that we can do
is just leave the damn stores up
because because they're like look like
at least the stores up till god of war
comes out
yes it comes down he's like we'll do it
the same day people won't even notice
they wouldn't care they care now because
we have nothing to show
exactly like yeah yeah i don't even have
any gains how are you going to take more
away from us
this is true when god of war comes out
then kill it
like he's kind of right there man let's
let's how much would it cost to keep it
up till god of war oh you don't know
when god of war is coming out
what's an estimate someone tell me i
need to know
20 23 sir okay how much would it cost to
go
we'll say 2024 just to be on the safe
side
next console sir they go a whole
generation with no games come on
oh no that's not gonna happen all right
so you know
that's how much i really have to think
about that i feel like
in terms of sony they try to pull fast
on all people
and they got the backlash and for the
once i i see a lot of
because i don't personally feel like
there's a media buys i feel like there
is a click bait
and the media is always going to the
direction that they can get the most
money out of
so if if the scenario's attacking
playstation
they're going to make the articles about
playstation if the scenario's attacking
xbox
they're going to make the articles about
xbox all they care about bottom line
and they'll make that title whatever
they can to bring in the people to make
that bottom line
i think honestly i've watched uh
the narrative change but not completely
i have i will always i would die on this
hill i believe that
they're used to being the media darling
i they're used to
getting car blanche uh to go here and to
go there and do whatever they choose
because they literally have no back
compact solution
uh and they told you like it's whatever
you know they they don't have to tell
you when
games are coming out they don't have to
tell you what's going on
they're not transparent at all and they
feel that they've built this cache
that they can do whatever they want to
do they had the same scenario the same
big-headedness
when they had the playstation 3 come out
and they were telling people you got to
get a second job and all this other
stuff
people really need to remember this is
revisionist history
but people need to really remember that
sony
was coming in on a way from the
playstation 2
and the playstation 2 was such a huge
success
i mean one to two it was amazing two
totally blew out one for me and going
into three i was already on board i
really didn't care
and i feel the same things happening
here the playstation 4
is really outstanding it was a great
system for a lot of customers
not for myself but riding that
goes to sushima riding that uh last of
us two
riding those games going into this this
riding spider-man god of war
riding these games going into the next
generation
they got big headed and you can tell
yeah you can tell by the concept i think
you could just tell by our
you know shout out to uh you know when
we did the
uh where we were talking about whether
or not the metacritic score on iop
it's like we had a dev that used to work
for for sony
that said that the longer he worked
there the more they pushed
up the concepts and what exactly they
wanted in terms of metacritic score it
just kept getting worse and worse
so now it's probably they are like look
like
sir these games are making money but are
they helping the narrative
no today's gone made money but it did
not help our narrative so get that up
out of here the developer told you
that it didn't the developer from dave's
gone told you that
if you wanted a sequel you should have
purchased the game at full price
you know from the beginning a lot of
these dudes brought days gone half price
or when it was in a bargain bin i wanted
to buy one get one free date
playstation collection yeah so you know
it didn't make well
quote-unquote full price but if you had
a solution and this is where i got to
say the genius of phil dominance maximus
really spencer comes into play
any game that's inside game pass is new
engagement you know type of thing and
while you're in game pass you're going
to purchase games
i've purchased i think more digital
games than i've done physically
because it's the click thing it's the
same thing with amazon in your hand you
have amazon in your hand
you want something you click it you get
it you're done you deal with the problem
later when you have to pay for it
and this is the same scenario all over
again
and people are not getting it they're
not understanding it
and i definitely agree uh would do you
personally feel like
that sony's you know preference when it
comes to
canceling games like days gone uh well
not cancelling them but not
letting them do a sequel is because of
the metacritic score or do you think it
was a multiple things
and metacritical was just one of them i
think they're at a point where
financially they can't miss
yeah i agree with this they they're too
scared yeah
they're too scared to to not invest
something that's not going to be of
anger
and they're scared that okay if this
game
if this game ends up because it took
them like six years to make the first
one
yeah like you know they might make it
quicker but what's quicker
four years well if they make the game in
three years
right because once you already have the
technology down pack you can refine the
technology and scale it up
you know to to whatever the current uh
stats are on the playstation 5 opposed
to the playstation 4
pro or the base right and these guys
were ready to go they had multiplayer
they had all these stuff
uh thought out you know shout out to hip
hop gamer uh because he did the
interview with the guys at the
developers
and um he had all the information on on
the sequel
listen you had sean layton that was
inside
the building then when games like this
were getting greenlit
concrete genie stuff like that games
that you know people was taking a fly on
ribbon
um a lot of their games that are uh
thoughtful
and you know um you wouldn't ever
receive from naughty dog you would have
never received the last of us
if jim dance rules ryan was in position
because
at that point in time naughty dog was
known for what making
uncharted the banger right so
when you pitch the last of us um i don't
get that that's not going to work
and plus in the long run they're they're
he's scared to not he's like you know he
did whatever he could to get
i'm convinced he got sean pushed out so
he he's sitting there
you know let's say he didn't get sean
push out he's like i'm he's
he's obsessed with not well sean not
being right
so he's like if i invest into this game
and it flops it's going to
bring down my uh estimates for that you
know that quarter
and then sean's gonna be right like yeah
yeah there's a lot of i feel like
there's there is a lot of competition
going on with these executives
especially you know present past
executives but you know
uh my last question with that is
the the individual that uh you know
david joffrey
interviewed he said that if you want the
studio
to succeed and make sequels buy their
game at full price
he didn't really give any kind of
incentive to like any conditions he was
just pretty much like blind by the game
don't look at reviews just buy it i
don't think he really meant this but we
have to go off what he said
do you agree that you should just blind
buy stuff without any research
just because you kind of like that
studio
okay the hell with that right um
i'm already spoiled by game pass i'm a
spoiled by netflix i'm spoiled by
amazon prime i'm spoiled by any services
that i have
i'm spoiled by hulu i don't even want to
go to the movie theater guys because hbo
max has got me spoiled let's let's just
keep it a buck
all right when you're able to get this
level of convenience right now right now
i just
ordered i'm i got down to a food service
right that's prepping my food for me
organic uh wholesome food prep
that will be dropped off at my door
every friday for the whole week
and it's got to the point where
convenience is what our life has turned
into
you know if it wasn't then we'll all be
walking to work instead of driving to
work
it is the level of convenience so when
you tell me to blindly go purchase your
product where somebody else is giving me
the convenience of trying
there would have never been demos out
back in the days
but game pass is the ultimate demo
because you have the whole game
you understand so if you don't believe
in your product your product should be
in a place where
you're able to touch it play it
purchase it and if you like it
now i understand what he's saying for
you to get green lit
you should be purchasing the game at
full price
that's from where he's working from
you understand that environment doesn't
have something
like a game pass where games can go to
live
and grow over time his game has to sell
for it to be a success
at full price and sony's a hierarchy
for them to get greenlit for the second
game and
i believe developers should not be
working under those conditions because
then that force is a different narrative
on it because if they don't make those
first week sales
those first month sales those first
quarter sales then they're sitting there
afraid that they're never going to make
another sequel to their beloved game so
i i think that's a terrible place to
work to be honest
and it doesn't work well let's take it
back uh shout out to us
definitely if you guys haven't looked we
just uh
uh interviewed obsidian we did it sunday
so definitely go out there and check
that out there's a fantastic interview
you know shout out to cognito for doing
all the prep work for that
uh you know in that interview they said
look like we're not the same obsidian
that we was
because now we're stable we don't have
to constantly work on a project and
imagine how mentally exhausting that is
like you know who else ninja theory
remember that they just they said the
same exact thing
i mean i mean not to cut you but
literally everybody thought ninja theory
was uh propped up and
like they were told what to say but if
another developer says the same exact
thing
at what point in time do you believe it
to be true it has to be true
and i definitely uh 100 agree with that
i i feel like
if you really want devs to be full
and to be the best they can it's got to
be in an environment where
they're not scared in a couple in a year
year and a half
the job security is horrible like in
probably the majority of this industry
like
unless you're a naughty dog 343 or
coalition
or uh you know saint monica you probably
do every project thinking this is
probably the last project we're ever
gonna do
and that's sad that really is but think
about it this way
sony of japan remember when sony japan
was the crown jewel in
sony's development uh houses
and they didn't turn out a winner in a
minute or whatever whatever they
consider to be a banger
you know um but for that to close down
like that could you imagine if microsoft
was to tell you that the coalition is
done
yeah it would it would it would be it
would be serious i think it's serious
that i know a lot of people
don't really like what sony japan was
doing but like they did a lot they
helped with bloodborne like
that's a studio that should not have
been shut down in my opinion if sean
layton was still in that none of this
stuff happens
so you think he he did it for financial
reasons like look you're not
you're not delivering what i feel like a
studio should be delivered in terms of
profit so
you got to get up out of here is that
what i think i think he
he's doing in
the same thing that the days gone
developer expressed
you don't buy games day one you're not
going to get a sequel
i definitely can see that yeah you know
so
talking about studios obviously we know
microsoft
they own a bunch of studios a bunch of
teams in the studios
26 you still 23 26 you're just like
let's
ball game it said you were between that
all right i'm gonna tell you something
so
wait a second okay time out
we joke but sony had a hidden studio
that was making games on the side and
nobody knew about them
right right or wrong okay thank you so
why can't microsoft have three shadow
studios excuse me
let's go and then plus you know i i
think people fail to realize that
a lot of these studios have multiple
teams too yeah like a lot of the
majority of them
so you know in all sense you see 23
studios it's probably like
in all sense like 35 to 40 teams
and they're all working on different
projects you know regardless if it's
triple a double a i don't like the
aaa argument because i feel like yeah
you know when it comes to games it's
games
it's like it's a good game some of the
best games i've played
has been indie games some of the best
games i've played been triple a games
the good game is a good game regardless
you know i i
lived and breathe and died star renegade
shout out to king because he's the one
that
told me about that you know i played
that game
like crazy right now i'm playing
octopath traveler so like to me
i want games that are good regardless
what kind of scenario they're in because
i feel like a lot of the indie
developers they they don't have they
don't have as much shackles on them as
is triple eight buttons but you know
we're going into e3
king obviously we got like pro a little
bit less than a month and a half
up until e3 now what i want from you
is what is your wants at e3 on sony
and microsoft what is this something i
want that and then
i'm going to ask you something after
that that's that that's going to be a
quick thing because i want
i want your opinion on that so right now
let's start with microsoft
you'll start with sony what is your
wants for sony
um the concrete release dates on some of
the games um to release the
the ssd expansion point uh
for the for the gamers um
uh that's about it you know games
and that ssd drive you know just that's
all
you know i don't i don't i don't really
want much from them
because right now they wouldn't offer
anything to me but
bangers uh oh okay you know what you
know what they can do for me
they can get playstation now and do date
and day i'd see
i won't i can't say that because i know
it's unrealistic
you know i know me saying these things
it's it's
unrealistic so i'm gonna give you
realistic scenarios i want the expansion
drive
uh to to actually take ssd and i want to
get a concrete
uh listing of games for the year that's
about it
so you don't want no type of gameplay or
anything like that you just want
realistic nah i think they're gonna show
a sizzle reel i think they're gonna show
some games
you know i honestly believe they're
gonna show you again they're gonna show
you
because around that time you're gonna
have uh ratchet and clank
uh um i believe they're gonna give you
uh some more gran turismo
they're gonna show you um probably a
sizzle reel of god of war
and of um of alloy and uh
horizon zero and then and maybe you may
get some concept
art of uh the new last of us um remix
so yeah do you think that might be there
no just just concept art you know just
like how um
uh ninja dairy did uh that thing like
the weird spot where they was
wherever they was in ireland or
something and it was showing you what
they were talking about so i think they
might do something like that
all right so so he here's here
here's what i have to say to you let's
say jim dan smith ryan
is done he's seeing king talking that's
that preach
every week he comes to you he's like
king what do we gotta do
what are you telling jim ryan to do with
the sony console oh if
if he wants to win if he wants to win
if if he wants to win he has the best he
has the better ips than microsoft
that he does yeah he does for now for
now
well at this moment he has the better
proven ips
period yeah so in doing in having that
okay so we release all our playstation
now all ips in playstation now
while our future releases will be date
and date
they're not going to walk back to 70
price so
they're not going to walk back to 70
price they're going to keep that 70
price
just make sure that your game's a date
and date
make sure that you get these services
out because
yeah you're doing it with the
playstation now monthly games
and they're far superior to xbox
gold games yeah
it's it's so much better it's become a
laughingstock to be honest yeah but xbox
go
i think microsoft purposely makes xbox
games with gold
i feel like at this point like it's it's
like they're they're buying the xbox
gold games with like the slush fund
money like
we were gonna spend this much money on
alcohol next year
all right let's let's buy these games
because i feel like their prime focus
is game pass and if they can get a
really good game for game pass they
would rather win the game
to go makes no sense so question is do
you think games ago should go away
i think games of gold should have been
rolled inside game pass a long time ago
and just remove games of gold
um make xbox live uh basically free
you know the mo they did that the
multiplayer they removed the barriers
um it's really no need it's redundant
yeah i definitely agree so this is this
is what i want this is what i think from
sony
i think they're probably going to go out
there show some games that are a little
bit closer like ryan trismo
i think they they'll probably cause i
don't think horizon's coming out this
year i think it's being pushed back
so i think they're going to show
gameplay of horizon and
i don't think they're show i think
they'll show a cgi scene
of god of war i don't think they're
showing game play god of war i think
game plays next year of god of war
verticals
and i think they'll show some indies and
i think they'll end it with like a brand
new ip from like a
a studio that's been working on a game
oh yeah i'm probably going to show it a
lot of that square enix game
yeah that is a good point they have
scoring unless microsoft buys
even if they do they still can show
their game i i think if if they bought
them
i don't think it would be on their stage
i think it will because that's the game
that they purchased that's a game that's
decided stable
as a game that's launching but did you
notice like when microsoft
bought bethesda they like slowed down on
the promotion of death loop and stuff
well they knew it wasn't coming out
right now so
now if dance move ryan came up to me
he's like addict
what do you need what do you think we
should do to combat game pass
i feel like you need to first off you
need to double down on your studios and
not necessarily buying studios but
the internal studios you know you need
to let these people be working on two
maybe even three games at the same time
uh you know so you're gonna have to
really double down on the studio size
because you're making the best games you
have the best talent you might as well
rotate between that talent
right uh i think that's their best bet
now i do think they need to buy studios
if they had the money to because here's
the thing people think they don't have
the money to buy someone like square
enix they do
but the thing is is it's harder to
convince
a board to put in probably 40 50
of your money uh that you got lying
around
into buying a studio publisher
and they they don't have the money they
would have to take a loan
and put assets against that loan and
then
i'm pretty sure the board would be like
nah
that's what i mean yeah exactly don't
don't you have stuff that we can buy
aren't they games that we can get
without going out you know
broke i feel like micros uh i feel like
sony needs to
get blue point they need to get remini
because i feel like remedy is such a
good line of the games that they already
make
that it wouldn't be hard to really
adjust and format that company
and to you know let's let's splash the
last of us template in there
oh wait who's the team who's the um the
developer that did
the remix of the last guardian
um i don't know someone in the chat say
while i look it up in case i i in case
they
last guardian yeah
i think that the last guardian was
developed
by team ico
japan studios wow
so i don't even have that anymore um i
think right now you you you let 90 dog
work on two games i wouldn't let naughty
dog work on more than two because
if you start who's the one that did the
shadow colossus remake
that was um that was blue point
blue point right yes that i think they
should buy blue point don't
i thought they owned them no it's a
second party studio
wow because okay to the best of my
knowledge they're doing something for
them
yeah i think they need to buy them they
need to buy remedy because i honestly
feel like
microsoft buys remedy i don't think it's
going to do too much because
they don't really have much chemistry
together you know what i'm saying but i
feel like if sony bought remedy
they could really capitalize on what
remedy does because
you know remedies literally just like
just like
a toss of a huh i'm not a huge fan of
him that's what i mean
remedy he's literally like a coin flip
away from being a last of us template
like it really is did see i thought that
the allen wake ip um
it's a real good ip i think the control
ip
is a good ip if if they would have the
financial backing
that quantum break did i think control
would have been ten times better
as far as story narrative going
everything like that because there was a
lot of broken parts
to that game i think quantum break is an
infinitely
better game story wise but i feel like
like i said before control
the control of the game and control is
better so that's why they called it
control i think
but remedy under the best conditions
can produce a quality stuff
and force i think that works
well with sony like you were saying
because you know um
the the third person over the shoulder
story driven so
that's what i'm saying man that's
literally they're screaming
by a sony we want to be owned like i i
feel like
when it comes to that i do i do i feel
like they're a good fit and
you know blue point remedy you know
chat put in the chat what studios you
feel like sony should buy
so you know that's what i feel like to
do so let's let's go and go with
microsoft so we can
wrap this up because i know you're tired
so let let's talk about
xbox uh first off let's see
uh i believe that they're i personally
think that their
conference is gonna be the 13th right uh
that's usually usually is that sunday
that's what i'm saying you know be crazy
if they do do sunday
we might have to push iop back that day
we can just do it tonight that's what i
meant we have to push it back that day
like
so let's talk about e3 this year
right what is something that you want
from microsoft
what is an announcement or maybe a
couple announcements what is the
announcements that are you
king david is looking forward to on
e3 stage this year okay so the stuff
that i don't know the stuff that i will
hope for mm-hmm
okay yeah yeah yeah let's let's let's
not snitch let's not stitch in turtle
secrets i would love i will love for
uh uh phil dominance maximus are really
expensive to be out on stage and you
need to hear a coin go off
and somebody in the sonic costume comes
running out
[Music]
and they purchase sega and you know the
you know the bigger question is can you
if phil called you and asked you to be
the the sonic which
i will dress up inside if they purchase
sonic i'll dress up in a sonic suit
with my face out oh definitely it will
be crazy
you just like you know how like like
phil just shows up randomly around the
stage when he does the e3 conferences
like in that middle part that he always
likes doing it's just like
the the the screen goes dark it patterns
around you hear a coin flip and you just
see you running down the middle
in a sonic suit what they do is they put
big quarters on the ground and you reach
down and pick all of them up
i'm not picking up anything he's gonna
run to the stage they better have
holographic coins
but um yeah yeah that you know um
going too far man you going too far i
like to see halo infinite
um make its uh triumphant uh
uh return and then and then on the
screen
i think they're gonna have a sizzle reel
you know they always do they always have
like 100 games
that they show that's here that's coming
so
[Music]
uh what i want i just want more games
um they're really hitting it out of the
park right now
so i just i just want more games i mean
my honest with you
these stuff the pie in the sky stuff i
know a lot of stuff is happening
i would like for them to say ubisoft is
is inside uh
um inside game pass so i can actually
play uh assassin's creed valhalla
so because i don't want to go spend the
money for it
yeah so that's that's it you know i
think for me
oh the the new elite oh the
elite uh version three you want yeah the
one that actually works with the series
x and series s
now what about these rumors going off
kojima do you want kojima to pop up on
that stage
i honestly think he's gonna be it that's
why i didn't say that
i mean it's it's out there everywhere
now yeah yeah
yeah well i honestly think he's gonna be
there so i honestly believe my scenario
like i said
and with the game that he's gonna do is
gonna blow your socks off i actually
believe that he's going to get the metal
gear uh ip
and they're going to do that and it is
going to be whatever i
honestly believe that they're going to
shut down e3
but in what i want to see
yeah i would love to see sun running
down the house you just gave me a vision
of
of the ultimate warrior running down in
a sonic suit
shaking the ropes hell yeah i'm down for
all of that
you you best believe it but i would love
for them to purchase another another
publisher
and i believe that publishing house is
sega
and you know i think they that
fits that niche
that they're looking for because sega
has a ton of ips you know jet set radio
um oh what is that uh uh
fantasy star and they can actually do
the real rpgs
you know it's a lot of stuff that they
can actually do you know besides sonic
uh
they can give us a lot of those games
like crazy taxi
you know it's a lot of stuff they can do
i'm down for all of that stuff from sega
and that's what's up so now let's say if
you
had one thing to go in there and change
one thing
that is going on with microsoft what
would it be
one thing inside microsoft
it could it could be maybe the direction
of a studio
or maybe there's a game going over there
you don't think it's going to be that
okay
one one thing that if i can just go in
there and fix it and just switch it
around
i would take bungie and put them ahead
of uh
halo infinite you know i don't care how
controversial that may sound to a lot of
people
i don't give a damn but if if if
i can switch stuff around because i
love uh destiny's gun play
i love how destiny feels um i would
i would honestly just hand it over to
bungie and
and tell bungie let's get busy let's
just really take this let's finish this
fight
and then that that that's that's that's
what i'll do
i honestly believe if if i can do it not
saying that 343 is a bad studio
not saying anything like that but i
don't really have too much problems with
microsoft as far as their direction and
where they're going
but if i can switch one thing it'll be
that
all right so i let me speed my talk real
quick
i personally at this e3 i want it to
focus on gameplay of games that we
currently have been announced
yeah um you know obviously there are
some studios that have
that have not been announced i i'm
pretty sure compulsions new game has
been announced there's a couple of
seconds uh
teams of current studios that haven't
been announced uh i want to see gameplay
of hellblade i want to see gameplay i
don't think
fable was a realm of possibility i'm
never going to see that
but i i will i want to in-depth gameplay
of
of halo right uh and i want to see it
single player and multiplayer i want
me you could even be scissorel at this
point you know what i'm saying but i
would like a gameplay
presentation of halo even if it's one of
those things where they have to do it
the next day
you know what i'm saying like where they
come up there they just show you a
little bit of thing they're like
tomorrow we're going to break this down
more you're going to see a little bit
more
go to the twitch channel or whatever or
you come over to iop
uh xbox you know we just saying that
we're just throwing that out there
uh i want to see that i feel like now in
terms of bethesda
the question i have for myself is
if they're going to be two or one show i
think they're going to be two shows
i think halo's ending i don't know halo
might
start the xbox show i don't think it's
going to end it and i think they'll
probably end the xbox show if like some
uh was some game that hasn't been
announced yet or
i will get to my predictions like that
week before
and what i believe they're going to
start and end with because right now
we're too far out
and i i can't i can't
i yeah this is just too far off me and i
think that the bethesda one
i think that they'll start that with
wolfenstein and they'll end that with um
starfield
question to you king starfill come out
this year or next year yeah this year
this year i think it's a pretty good
chance i think it's a really good show
yeah i think it's november
and you know i just i feel like this
year
halo is september october oh you think
you think it's that early yep i think
because game pass changes when you
launch and how you launch
so um to get that that
to get you back to school money i
believe they'll they'll get you in
september
and remember bungie is in the building
doing something so we won't have
uh destiny dropping in september this
year
so you know you might have an update or
something like that here's my question
you think gear shows up at e3 this year
no i think that's a e through next year
yeah
uh and the reason i think that is
because i think gears would probably be
ready to come out next year
but now since they have all these
studios they have bethesda now we're
gonna have scenarios where they have to
push stuff back that's
full-blown ready because they have too
much stuff coming out as it is
yeah they have to space it they have to
have those uh two to three month gaps
between
uh heavy hitting games so they can have
enough time to breathe inside game pass
and you know to to keep that recurring
dollar up because
let's say this and and i've noticed this
should be the cadence
um and i don't like to do the triple a
thing but
triple a titles are dropping game pass
uh two times a year
in between those spaces because they're
six months apart
and in between those spaces you have uh
two to three uh double
a and a single lay you have probably
four single light
within the year so you space out the
year that way
and you know single a quote-unquote you
know because
what's that game that everybody's
talking about that the game was
that was on switch like zeus what was
that um a hades
hades right um i think that might show
up at e3 on my career
stage yeah but that game was like a uh
indie game you understand
so some people will look at that game as
a a single a game
so those games like that would be
prevalent inside game pass so
they have to sprinkle it out in order to
give game pass longevity and not
overwork the studios to be honest with
you yeah
you know shout out to the 220 people in
the chat man i appreciate you guys
coming through you know you definitely
want to be present for iop sunday it's
going to be crazy we
we we have a good guess for you guys we
have good topics it looks like you guys
you're definitely
not going to want to miss that hit that
like button man let's get those likes
above 100 before the end of the show
but you know that's pretty much all for
the show of ad you know we we definitely
uh e3 uh i'm pretty sure that we're
going to do our um
our our yeah our prediction our e3
prediction shows i'm pretty sure those
are coming back
so definitely be looking out for that we
are scouring guests right now
i appreciate everyone for coming through
king where can they find you besides
on twitter making people look like a
fool well
the video's coming for mlb the show um
i have to go down my bed first
and um you can catch me on like i said
on twitter that's about it right now oh
oh uh
uh what is it uh dolph castle x friday's
9 p.m
definitely gonna love this week this
week we're going to somebody posted a
laura crawford tomb raider retro statue
and that statue looks nice so
we're going to go in depth about that
statue um a lot of other statues that
are that's coming out i got some statues
coming in so i got to do an unboxing
and i got to finish up this one uh yeah
i was having a problem with my
uh my gopro and um actually uh
fix it you know the new software on the
gopro i had to wait for an update had to
do a whole bunch of stuff
so kos is coming you know attic helps
out with that
so that stuff would be up so you can
check that out soon that'll be with that
green goblin that's why the gopro's
right there
that green goblin looked pretty lit man
i ain't going to lie like
that green goblin you if you guys i have
your screen up
if you guys want to see that green
goblin definitely be on the lookout for
that
kos statue man you know king gonna break
that the king teaches me more about the
marvel universe than marvel teaches me
so you know i definitely you know
appreciate king taking the time out of
his day to come on here
uh you know we're gonna go ahead and uh
wrap up the show like i said you
definitely want to be here for iop
sunday don't miss it
you're gonna regret it if you ain't so
uh until iop we'll see you guys later
i don't know what i'm gonna do i'm
probably gonna try to do these attic
shows every tuesday with a different
guest
uh i don't like having more than three
people because i like keeping this 45
minutes to an hour long
i don't like making the show longer
because there's a lot of shows that's
already long
and iop is already almost three to four
hours every week
so i ain't trying to to put more
of a watch growth on that i want people
you know be able to come in here
you know see a couple people really
breaking down a topic and then we're
going to keep it going
like i said sunday 1 p.m eastern we're
going to be announcing the guests later
on this week i think
some of you guys will definitely enjoy
the guests and until next time this is
gaming addict in